Michael Rapaport who joins us here on
the Rich Eisen show in person
Michael is part of the cast of fantasy
zone this season the senior fantasy
football analyst for red zone good to
see you thank you I appreciate although
as you know as you you respect yeah me
working blue when we text one another
yes this is asked to be a safe for work
broadcast absolutely um why do I call
you a senior fantasy football analyst
when in the Alice in Chains league that
Brockman and I are currently leading
with the most points most wins and now
have already a Carlos Hyde performance
in our back pocket for week three why do
I call you
senior llama grief is that right I'm
great at fantasy football I I know my
stuff I've come on this show I've given
great hot takes and all of them I'd say
about 75% of them been good the real
question is is rich yeah is you have a
show yeah you you did a fantastic job
with a great game on Thursday Night
Football last week last night your your
sports guy yes you got your flunky your
henchmen doing your draft for you
flunky Huntsman Brockman client name all
the way you did a great job but like are
you getting painted to do this guy's
drafts or anything yeah I mean not cash
forget what you get over here they're
the stacks of money you make over I'm
saying is my man throwing you cash to do
his draft to try to make him look sort
of decent we have an arrangement see now
here's the thing basically this is this
is grade a it's deflecting grade a
deflecting right now cuz it's just like
instead of talking about being Owen too
but because he lost by point one point
two Duff McKagan point one point two
Duff McKagan
of Guns and Roses fame you know instead
of owning it instead of owning it you
try and deflect on on an unbearable to
unbesmirched guess it is that's a real
word straight from the dominating dotard
gallery of words let me take something
let me tell you some rich yes Michael I
blame the guy who's League it is Jerry
Cantrell big rock star with his Allison
chains
japanese guitars beautiful house spotty
internet so you're spending them in the
wall in place cuz my team my team otto
drafted four guys I am a senior fantasy
football annals every single draft I
make I have to be able to stand behind
and explain for the guys I couldn't pick
him out of a lineup so are you the
redheaded stepchildren on my team so I
blame Jerry Cantrell and his crappy
internet it's like you got all he's got
beautiful art beautiful furniture crappy
internet baby
maybe so you're saying the the reason
why you're owing to in this lien week
three in this league is is as Jerry
Cantrell his IT guy that's the guy
you're blaming no no not his IT guy I'm
blaming Jerry Cantrell himself fantastic
okay Wow he's on tour he's never stopped
making with the money just it's like
spitting it out get your net fix my man
so what the nineties but at least you
had Pierre Garcon last night right
that's right you had him yep I had him
last night
and he you know he did very well and
I've been talking about here all aldress
mock season and all the rest marks you
know that direst mock draft that was I
mean last night was so much fun isn't
crime I mean he's a fan rich did you
have a ball I didn't I did and plus
there was a Brockman and L Tufo were
there as well in the green room watching
Marshall Faulk watch the Rams you
brought them with you yeah we should we
did the show from there yesterday nice
they they were part of don't shine shoes
no more that's right yeah you've been
away a long time there's no shine box
for those guys blow shine box no shine
vines come on but Marshall was into it
I mean he's excited that the Rams look
like this and what this is is a bonafide
offensive team my phone what's on air is
that right you know what no one
important all right that's who is it who
is it nobody important sure nobody
important if it was somebody good at
answering but it's my fault okay but can
connect you in something this by the way
that's a $10 fine on the research I'm
really sorry about that embarrassing but
so do you know what I was happy about
for you and for the NFL and for Thursday
Night Football yes the haters
complaining about Thursday Night
Football
you know what if you're a real football
fan you want to complain about Thursday
Night Football watch Dancing with the
Stars Derrick
sure Mita made a mockery of himself last
night on Dancing with the Stars
don't complain about Thursday night
football there's plenty of other things
to watch shut up and then get off the
internet if it's so bad why are you
talking about it I watch it every single
week if it's Thursday Sunday there's
good games Monday this bad game Sunday
shut your mouth and watch Derek Fisher
make a fool himself on Dancing with the
Stars I applaud you sir I stand and
applaud you next week's gonna be a good
game Julie you got one of the best
football players ever Aaron Rodgers yes
got an exciting yet not very good
Chicago Bears team yes and you got my
main man my favorite player in the NFL
right now has ty Montgomery number 88
converted wide receiver to a bang him up
through some old school running backs I
love that dude so next Thursday's gonna
be good to see don't like it watch days
of her life on repeat recorded and shut
your mouth of no one cares about tweets
I don't game was great last night
Michael Rapaport a senior senior there
you go fantasy football analyst at
fantasy football analyst here you go so
you could say it who do you have you
come every week hype players and hype
that shouldn't be believed let's start
but don't believe the hype don't believe
the hype and see this week yes
deshaun Watson love you but Billy the
chin Belichick is going to eliminate
your number one weapon and you're gonna
be running for your life this week verse
New England okay
DeAndre Hopkins is not gonna be a fact
that he does Belichick always take away
the one thing that you covet the most
yes and that is do DeAndre Hopkins yes
and he's gonna rookie him he's going to
rookie him Billy Billy belch in mmm
Billy Bell a cheat yes he did I say
cheat I'm sorry Billy Bell a check look
huh he's going to he's going to
eliminate that he's gonna have a tough
time this week Leonard fournette these
games in London no good they're shopping
they're playing the Ravens they have a
tough line no shopping no you know
they're always like they show them
shopping at Harrods they're having of
the tea cream it's too much traveling
it's too much shopping it's too much
Prince Harry I just know are you saying
people should bench land it for no no
I'm not saying bench him I'm not saying
necessarily bench him but you should can
you could consider benching him okay you
have to it
I don't know everybody's team although I
know a lot I don't know everybody's team
sure I'm saying I have him in the Howard
Stern fantasy football league where I'm
actually leading a first place
destroying everybody okay ruin him yeah
I may or may not play him I may or may
not play him so I'm not saying bench him
but in daily fantasy football
I wouldn't go lay away from me I would
not go with him not Marcus Mariota
yes no DeMarco no Corey Davis the Legion
of boom Marcus Mariota has not made that
jump that we expected him listen I know
we got a broken leg last year I
understand I have compassion that
there's no jokes about that but he also
seems hesitant to take off which is one
of his assets his first few years in the
league I am a big Marcus Mariota fan I
drafted him in my poker league is that
working I somebody in my league I don't
know who did draft Matthew Stafford and
I picked him up and I'm gonna start him
this week instead of Marcus Mariota you
know why I love Mariota I just this is
the week where I just I'm not gonna go
into the game with him like that and you
know what you like him but you know what
the key is rich no feelings in fantasy
that's there's no commitment in fantasy
football I love you Marcus Mariota you
could be my cousin you could be my son
if he was my son
bencher asses well I'm gonna take a
break right now when we come back I want
players to believe the hype maybe
there's a couple of people that may
might even be on a waiver wire you never
know I gave a good one in yesterday's
show if you watch the show instead of
listening to it hmm you may have missed
that name I'll give it again right here
somebody who's definitely available on
your waiver wire that I think is gonna
be a big-time running back in this
league by the end of the season if not
an in shorter time I've got Michael
Rapaport here we've got Rashad Jennings
making his way to the studio here
speaking of Dancing with the Stars yes
he's in this our Robert Patrick and our
number three the actor the actor it's a
guy he's coming
I like him he's good at me too he's a
big Falcons fan too in lines
found a big marquee game this week we've
got Michael Rapaport here and your phone
calls at 844 204 rich hang on we'll take
those calls here on this edition of the
Rich Eisen show C key is you have the C
key cap on your phone
duh of course of course you do Michael
Rapaport is a CD cap I have it our
coordinating producer Don Bowie went to
the Los Angeles Angels game yesterday
yeah hit the seat geek button yesterday
morning yeah hit the button and had the
tickets boom it was so simple the only
problem is some animal down the road
from him took this his shoes off there's
nothing you can do with the seat geek
app with that is there I haven't I
haven't seen the filter know give me
tickets away from some animal that's
gonna take their shoes off at the
stadium haven't seen that they have on
flip-flops
no no socks even I wouldn't do that
Savage
so you know that's is that your area
when you do when you do fantasy area
okay so I don't know why we got all this
this up here cuz it's it's the Rich
Eisen show right now I understand that
but this is my little plot of land in
the Rich Eisen studio yes and basically
you've thrown up propaganda in my spot
in my area cuz come Sunday fantasy zone
this is the Rappaport this is the
Rappaport area they call it the feet the
Rappaport man-cake well we got to come
up with a better than Rappaport rathole
or what are we gonna come at works but
if the gorgeous are not so Richard it's
how great it is I know we can't call it
a rathole that's bad
please all I like are the Rappaport
commands sent the rathole zone the rapp
zone the rapp zone the fantasy zone wrap
zone the place that winners sit no
winners sit here my friends nothing you
think I'm sweating about that I means do
nothing to me I'm like okay okay what do
you know what you've won this week was
the first bit of the the first spot in a
waiver wire pickup that's what you won
this week well you said you had a waiver
wire
oh not more in the league I picked him
up dude come on I'm not gonna give out
facts and not use them what's coming up
you want to share it with the rest the
world just clean your crap up on Sunday
when you're done over there that's all I
care about just clean your crap up
wheels up took us home after the game
last night so I could be here in person
to talk to Michael Rapaport good to see
you sir that's why you rushed back huh
well ah no no but I just like to make my
guests feel feel good okay that's me
yeah I got it you know I'm a giver I'm a
giver but I like to give the grief to
certainly to those who are owned two in
our league and uh you know last night or
if you saw the pregame I know you saw
the game oh yeah did you see our pregame
show on the info yeah did you see well I
know my two guys over there saw cuz they
were in the greenroom a Michael Irvin
and LaDainian Tomlinson did the old
split-screen it turned it on I I don't
know I thought I was I was on one of
those argument shows for second over you
know LT called Ezekiel Elliott he didn't
call him a quitter on an NFL game day
prime Sunday night he said that he quit
on his team and Irvin said that that is
the worst word you can use for a
competitor in the sport and that LT
should know better you say that but he
definitely implied that knowing that
that would be applied to this young man
throughout the week where do you stand
on a zekiel Elliot and what happened
last week well he he didn't play good I
think on that play that that they're
talking about though the fumble
he gave up he did there's a lot going on
in his world he's a young kid we don't
know what he's done what he hasn't done
and he had a bad game I mean it's like
gloom or doom with you know there's so
many opinions there's so many thoughts
the Cowboys had a bad game they got
their butts handed to them yeah and
he'll bounce back you know like believe
the hype on xzq alley it's not gonna
like all of a sudden he's dropping down
the tubes he's not gonna like you know
all of a sudden become an average
playing a bad game against a Superbowl
caliber defense yeah I know I'm glad I'm
not going against him this week although
Arizona is you know no slouch I think
that they're gonna be home and that
they're gonna give Dallas a hell of a
game everybody thinks in Arizona and
over the first two weeks has not done
very well you haven't which is true and
that that that's the way they're gonna
play in week 3 and beyond I would
disagree
with that I disagree with that also a
Patrick Peterson do not believe the hype
on Dez Bryant again that's three weeks
in a row it's gonna get better
here's here's a fantasy move try to
trade for Dez Bryant he's gonna have a
bad weekend and then money be like hey
give dad's to me you know I'll give you
this one in that one ni because it's
gonna change okay cuz he's on the death
row he had the Giants generis Jenkins
shut him down and then he had no fly
zone Aqib Talib and then this weekend
it's gonna be another tough matchup run
things are gonna get better and he's
gonna have Jim Norris again but Dez is a
guy you should try to trade for a
fantasy for B well certainly I wouldn't
trade him knowing that the Rams are
right around the corner based on what we
saw last night with your guy Pierre
Garcon yes and then when we left we saw
that the next home game for the 49ers is
gonna be against the Cowboys so Dez is
gonna have that team that gave up not
one but two 100-yard wide receivers
levels no work somebody in your league
like Oh
dad's had another bad weekend I'll take
him for these two scrubs and then it'll
pay off he is there so who in the stern
league would buy that sort of business
who can you fleece in the stern league
nobody wants to trade with me in any of
my leagues I don't know why we got this
guy he comes on the show
Fabiano he he offers me trades yeah I
don't trip we did oh well we did make a
dream last year or is that two years ago
with fabs he offers the worst trades I'm
like who do you think you talked to to
my man I know it's not happening Cole
call someone else mm-hmm here's the
dial-a-joke
don't call me fat fabs is to know as
well in our league as well he's got a
good team and he got this he picked
Ezekiel and he would throw he's gonna be
suspended and he's still one with him
having a horrible week last week so who
to who should I be believed for this
week believe the hype on which players
okay well you know I'm a Giants fan and
with shards coming in here Jennings is
coming in here defensively believe the
hype daily fantasy football on the
Philadelphia Eagles verse the humdrum
New York Giants the vultures of the
ether picked up the Eagles this week
we're playing we're playing them against
Oriole
we got them okay so we're believing that
hype yeah believe your talk from us on
that one yes Big Mike Evans he's going
against Rhodes who shut down sort of
Antonio Brown
sweet this roads tough big big Mike
Evans is bigger Clash of the Titans
never bet against Big Mike Evans he's
going to get his points in fantasy
football this week and by the way
speaking of the Minnesota Vikings Chris
Mortensen just broke this piece of news
involving Sam Bradford that Bradford
tested out his knee that kept him out of
that game against the Pittsburgh
Steelers last week and that Bradford is
seeking a second opinion from the old
these are the three words you never want
to have associated with you Oh dr. James
Andrews later today according to sources
Andrews the one who did the ACL repairs
plural on the left knee I mean this is
coming out of absolutely nowhere
Bradford was the NFC Offensive Player of
the week in week one and now here comes
case keenum
I know one of the guys I'm playing
against in my other league they've got
the bucks stashed the Bucks D stashed on
there but they it's either the Bucks D
or the Broncos D which one would you
choose
knowing that it's Casey I always go with
the Broncos d I'll go with the Broncos d
for daily ah no no no right Nate they
have both of them and they have a choice
against me this week my own reason why I
asked your advice is because I know it's
gonna be completely wrong oh no help me
out this weekend oh yes ahead now send
you a little chance a little
head-to-head daily head takers who wants
to wait for one match up in the Allison
changes head how about my team against
your team this week your vultures my rag
tag League that were joined bad bad in
and I'm talking about daily we go head
to head
you keep these two goons these two
flunkies you tell to foe and this guy
keep them out of it and we make it 10
bucks min 10 box with a cheeseburger
cheeseburger I allowed to do this as an
NFL employee can I do daily fantasy I
don't believe I can oh wait we're
nervous here no I'm not nervous I'll do
it for free
the last thing I'm doing for free for
free for free just for just just so I
could come here I mean stuffing next
week I'm not even on a daily fantasy
sighs good job gotta clean the studio
again
tomorrow I do I need a dress written
consent from the Commissioner than a
cause by my journal you don't want to do
that no I do that thank you Mark you
don't want to do that you see if you
could get some express written what is
it consent said yes from it from the
Commissioner you say the footballer you
see if you can work it out or we just
don't wait for me and Brockman versus
you and whoever your flunky is got no
flunky okay and you and complaining
about the bad Wi-Fi and Jerry Cantrell
Sally let's just do my team against
yours you already had a great night from
Pierre garçon I had a great night from
Carlos Hyde with Brockman put your money
where your mouth I can't you tell you
some of the people on that team they
will Otto Jeff that I don't even like
those dudes there's a feud I'm fixing it
up okay but right now I couldn't even
rattle off my lineup because I'm not
emotionally involved it's all about the
emotion for you it's all about the honey
for me not about the money Rick maybe
you're just concerned because the last
time you and I did some sort of thing
and fantasy football you wound up
cleaning the studio up we put you in
some sort of janitor outfit spit-shine
boy you took some sort of sprain sprayed
it all over the place and it stunk to
high heaven because you had no idea what
you were doing I spit shine this
beautiful I just want to support that
action with you rich
I want that action I don't want to wait
given it to you I want that actually
team going against Tory hold on ro who
you're going against this week doesn't
matter
Scotty so it's as if you're not going to
let's do it I'll fine I'll do that too
but I want you to see if you can express
written consent to me five bucks five
bucks you can't even get a cheeseburger
in LA for five bucks I'm gonna do lunch
we're gonna do a lunch fine finding for
a lunch steak and lobster
surf and turf man all right very good
who else you got him there you believe
the hype list right there anybody who's
wearing a Dolphins uniform and that
means Larry Csonka Bob Griese is the
Jets Dan Marino if you can if you could
wage those has put them all in there
because anybody that's wearing a
Dolphins uniform this week including
smoking Jay Cutler
good old dude throw a je Devante Parker
bring em all Jason Jason Taylor you
might even play tighter anybody greasy
anything that has anything that ever
played for the Dolphins
I think JLo owns a piece of the team put
her in your daily you'll be fine like
a-rod yes boom boom boom boom boom I
like that I like that rich oh my gosh oh
my guys believe the hype on those guys
that's a Michael Rapaport ur and believe
the hype you got anything on what the
NBA is right around the corner before I
let you go what are you that I know like
if I I stand behind Charles Barkley what
he said
he said in a lot of words I call it the
skinny Gina fication of the NBA and and
you know people like he's hating Charles
Barkley is a wealthy successful person
when he played when he didn't play
there's probably maybe two or three guys
that will be lucky enough to be revered
as much as Charles Barkley 20 years
after their career I totally agree with
everything he said I'm concerned about
the NBA also I'm concerned it's starting
October 17th yes well they did that on
purpose because they don't know that
they dressed well it's not the date 19
year old needs me rest but here's the
thing is I said this on yesterday's show
might as well bring it up here again
what is it no what I said is that is it
the players we're saying I don't want to
play or it's some actuary that's sitting
in the front office that says based on
the metrics that I know makes you sleep
that's what I'm saying is it I don't
know I don't know if it's a player
saying I don't want to play these back
they did it they said it they've made it
very apparent rich listen these guys are
incredible
but when I was 19 I played in the park
in the streets of New York for nine
hours a day granted I wasn't moving very
fast but the next day I got paid for
nine more hours there's just too much
debutante
babysitting ballerina bull crap in the
NBA and I think in the long run you're
you're gonna alienate the fans with this
stuff this is just too much everybody
wants to there's like one or two or
three guys that are the great great
great and everybody wants to brand
themselves and their sneakers and the
t-shirts and names it's like at the end
of that you got a
show and prove men well I just think it
would be more harmful if they don't play
when they show up to a town and
everybody's bought the tickets filled
and every share but if the skinny jean
off' occation actually allows the
players to play every that that will at
least do something with the fanbase
instead of turning them off that would
turn them off mark my words
okay dudes who are not injured will
still set out games this year the only
person in the league and you know i
can't stand them
but he's the greatest the only person in
the league right now who deserves to
give himself a break is LeBron because
of the tread on the tires
yeah he's never stopped playing he's
always in the finals he's always the man
the work look other than that everybody
should be playing Michael Rapaport check
him out on fantasy zone from the wrap
zone
yes we're calling it over there part of
the Rich Eisen show set is where he's
gonna be part of fantasy zone on channel
704 only on DirecTV this weekend at
Michael Rapaport on Twitter we'll see
you next Friday sir I cannot wait to
watch you on the next Thursday night
game keep kicking butt every Thursday
night boy thanks for your support the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy